the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay we're ready to start the eleventh
lecture we're still in the middle of up
sketching and indeed one of the reasons
why we did not talk about hyperbolic
functions is that we're running just a
little bit behind and we'll catch up a
tiny bit today and I hope all the way on
Tuesday of next week so let me pick up
where we left off with sketching so this
is a continuation all right I want to
give you one more example of how to
sketch things and then we'll go through
systematically so the second example we
did it one example last time is this the
function is X plus 1 over X plus 2 and
I'm going to save you the time right now
this is very typical of me especially if
you're in a hurry on an exam I'll just
tell you what the derivative is so in
this case it's 1 over X plus 2 the
quantity squared now the reason why I'm
bringing this up this example up even
though it'll turn out to be a relatively
simple one to sketch is that it's easy
to fall into a black hole with this
problem ok so let me just show you this
is not equal to 0 ok it's never equal to
0 so that means there are no critical
points ok at this point students many
students who have been trained like
monkeys to do exactly what they've been
told suddenly freeze and give up because
there's nothing to do so this is the one
thing that I have to train out of you
you can't just give up
at this point so what would you suggest
okay can anybody get us out of this Jam
yeah right so the suggestion was to find
the x-values where f of X is undefined
in fact so now that's a fairly
sophisticated way of putting the point
that I want to want to make which is
that what we want to do is go back to
our precalculus skills and just plot
points okay
so instead you go back to precalculus
and you plot some points it's a
perfectly reasonable thing now it turns
out that the most important points to
plot is the one that's not there namely
the value at x equals negative two which
is just what was suggested namely we
plot the points where the function is
not defined okay so how do we do that
well you have to think about it for a
second and I'll introduce some notation
when I do it if I evaluate two at this
place actually I can't do it I have to
do it from the left and the right so if
I plug in minus two on the positive side
from the right that's going to be equal
to minus two plus 1 divided by minus two
a little bit more than minus two plus
two which is negative one divided by now
this denominator is negative two a
little more than that plus two so it's a
little more than zero all right and that
is well we'll fill that in in a second
everybody's puzzled yes
not differentiate how to differentiate
it okay
I already got for something else a
little puff now I'm focusing on the
weird spot yeah would it be a little
less than zero okay so that's that's a
very good point this is a matter of
notation here and a matter of
parenthesis so wouldn't this be a little
lesson too well if it were if the
parenthesis were this way that is two
plus with a minus
after I did the two plus then it would
be less but it's it's this way okay
so the notation is you have a number and
you take the plus part of it that's
that's the part which is a little bit
bigger than all right and so this is
what I mean
all right and if you like here I can put
in those parentheses - yeah another
question why the only reason why the top
one doesn't matter plus is that I don't
need it to evaluate this it's going to
and when I take the limit I can just
plug in the value whereas here I'm still
uncertain because it's going to be zero
and I want to know which side of zero
it's on whether it's on the positive
side of the negative side all right so
this one it could I could have written
here a parenthesis two plus but then it
would have just simplified to negative 1
in the limit alright so now I've got a
negative number divided by a tiny
positive number and so somebody want to
tell me what that is negative in it okay
so we just evaluated this function from
one side and if you follow through the
other side so this one here you get
something very similar except that this
should be whoops what did I do wrong
I didn't why do I I guess I mean I meant
this okay I want to - to the same base
point but I want to go from the left
all right so that's going to be negative
two plus one same numerator and then
this is a negative two on the Left plus
two and that's going to come out to be
negative one divided by zero minus which
is plus alright or just plain infinite
you don't have to put the plus sign in
okay now so this is the first part of
the problem and the second piece to get
us our selves started you could evaluate
this function at any point this is just
the most interesting point all right
this is just the most interesting place
to evaluate it now the next thing that
I'd like to do is to to pay attention to
the ends and I haven't really said what
the ends are so the ends are just all
the way to the left and all the way to
the right so that means X going to plus
or minus infinity all right so that's
the second thing I want to pay attention
to again this is a little bit like a
video screen here and we're about to
discover something that's really off the
screen in both cases all right we're
taking care of what's happening way to
the left way to the right here and up
above we just took care of what happens
way up and way down all right so on
these ends I need to do some more
analysis which is related to a
precalculus skill which is evaluating
limits and here the way to do it is to
divide by X in numerator and denominator
right as a 1 plus 1 over X 1 plus 2 over
X and then you can see what happens as X
goes to plus or minus infinity it just
goes to 1 all right so no matter whether
it's X is positive or negative when it
gets huge these two extra numbers here
go to 0 and so this tends to 1 so if you
like you could abbreviate this as f plus
or minus infinity is equal to 1 alright
so now I get to draw this and we draw
this using
Toad's so there's a level which is y
equals one and then there's another line
to draw which is which is x equals
negative two
all right and now what information do I
have so far well the information that I
have so far is that when we're coming in
from the right that's this two negative
two it goes plunges down to minus
infinity so that's down like this okay
and I also know that it goes up to
infinity on the other side of the
asymptote and over here I know it's
going out to two what the level one and
here it's also going to the level okay
now there's an issue I can almost finish
this graph now I almost have enough
information to finish it but there's one
thing which is making me hesitate a
little bit and that is I don't know for
instance over here whether it's going to
maybe dip below and come back up or not
so what does it do here can anybody see
yeah
it can't dip below because there are no
critical points what a precisely correct
answer so that's exactly right the point
here is that because f prime is not 0 it
can't double back on itself because
there can't be any of these horizontal
tangents all right
it can't double back so it can't can't
backtrack so sorry if F prime is not 0 F
can't backtrack all right and so that
means that it doesn't look like this it
just goes like this all right so that's
basically it that's practically the end
of the problem that goes like this all
right now you can decorate your thing
right you may notice that it maybe it
crosses here the axes you can actually
evaluate these places and so forth we're
looking right now for qualitative
behavior in fact you can see where these
places hit and it's actually a little
higher up than I drew maybe I'll draw it
accurately so that you can see it as
we'll see second all right
anyway so that's that's what happens to
this function now let's just take a look
in a little bit more detail by double
checking so we're just going to double
check what happens to the sign of the
derivative and in the meantime I'm going
to explain to you what the derivative is
and also talk about the second
derivative so first of all the trick for
evaluating the derivative is an
algebraic one I mean obviously you can
do this by the quotient rule but I just
point out that this is the same thing as
this alright and now it has a whoops
that should be a 2 in the denominator
and so now this has the form 1 minus 1
over X plus 2 so this makes it easy to
see what the derivative is because the
derivative of
constant is zero right so this is
derivative is just going to be switch
the sign this is what I wrote before all
right and that explains it but
incidentally it also shows you that that
this is a this is a hyperbola right
these are just two curves of a hyperbola
okay
so now let's check the sign it's already
totally obvious to us that this is just
a double check we didn't actually I even
have to pay any attention to this it had
better be true this is just going to
check our arithmetic namely it's
increasing here it's increasing there
that's got to be true and sure enough
this is positive as you can see it's 1
over a square so it is increasing so we
checked it but now there's there's one
more thing that I want to just have you
watch out about so this means that F is
increasing on the interval minus
infinity X to minus 2 and also from
minus 2 all the way out to infinity so I
just want to warn you you cannot say
don't say f is increasing on minus
infinity infinity you are all X ok this
is just not true
all right I've written it on the board
but it's wrong I'd better get rid of it
there it is get rid of it okay and the
reason is so first of all it's totally
obvious it's going up here but then it
zooms back down there and here this was
true but only if X is not negative 2 so
there's a break and you've got to pay
attention to the break so basically the
the moral here is that if you ignore
this place it's like ignoring Mount
Everest or the Grand Canyon you're
ignoring the most important feature of
this function here if you're going to be
figuring out where things are going up
and down which is basically all we're
doing you'd better pay attention to
these kinds of places right so don't
don't ignore them all right so that's
the first remark and now there's just a
little bit of decoration as well which
is the role of the second derivative so
we've written down the first derivative
here the second derivative is now
negative two over X plus two cubed right
so so right I get that from
differentiating this formula up here for
the for the first derivative and now of
course that's also only works for X not
equal to negative two and now we can see
that this is going to be negative let's
see where is it negative when this is a
positive quantity so when negative 2 is
less than X is less than infinity it's
negative and this is where this thing is
concave let's see did I say that right
negative right this is concave down all
right and similarly if I look at this
expression the numerator is always
negative but the denominator becomes
negative as well when X is less than
negative 2 so this becomes positive
right so this case it was negative over
positive in this case it was negative
divided by negative so here this is in
the range minus infinity less than X 2
and here it's concave up
all right now again this is just
consistent with what we already guess
and of course we already know it in this
case if we know that this is a hyperbola
that it's going to be concave down to
the right of the vertical line dotted
vertical line and concave up to the left
so what extra piece of information is it
that this is giving us
did I say this backwards no I don't say
thanks okay so what extra piece of
information is is giving us it looks
like it's giving us hardly anything and
it really is giving us hardly anything
but it is giving us something that's a
little aesthetic it's ruling out the
possibility of a wiggle okay
there isn't anything like that in the
curve okay it can't shift from curving
this way to curving that way to curving
this way all right that doesn't happen
so so this is the these properties say
there's no wiggle okay all right so
question
sometimes
okay so the question is in this course
are we going to define positive
derivative as being the same thing as
increasing and the answer is no we'll
try to use these terms separately what's
always true is that if F prime is
positive then F is increasing but the
reverse is not necessarily true it could
be very flat the derivative can be 0 and
it still the function can be increasing
okay the derivative you places yeah for
instance like a cubic some cubics all
right other questions all right so so
that's as much as I need to say in
general I mean in a specific case but I
want to get you a general scheme and
then I want to go through a more
complicated example that gets all the
features of this kind of thing so so
let's talk about a general strategy for
sketching so the first part of the
strategy if you like let's see I have it
all plotted out here so I'm going to
make sure I get it exactly with the way
I wanted you to say oh okay so I kept
it's plotting the plot thickens here we
go all right so plot what is it that you
should plot first before you even think
about derivatives you should plot
discontinuities especially the infinite
ones all right that's the first thing
you should do and then you should plot
endpoints or ends or X going to also
minus infinity if if there don't happen
to be any
any finite ends to the problem and the
third thing you can do is plot any any
easy points this is this is optional and
at your discretion you might for
instance on this example plot the places
where the graph crosses the axis alright
if you want to alright so that's the
first part and again this is all
precalculus so now in the second part
we're going to solve this equation and
we're going to plot the critical points
and values alright in the problem which
we just discussed there weren't any so
this part was empty
alright so the third step is to decide
whether F prime sorry whether F prime is
positive or negative
on each interval between critical points
discontinuities the direction of the
sign in this case it doesn't change it
goes up here and it also goes up here
but it could go up here and then come
back down so the the direction can
change at every critical point you can
change it every discontinuity and you
don't know however this particular step
has to be consistent
with 1 & 2 with steps 1 & 2
in fact it will never if you can succeed
in doing steps 1 & 2 you'll never need
step 3 all it's doing is double check ok
so if you made an arithmetic mistake
somewhere you'll be able to see it so
that's maybe the most important thing
and it's actually the most frustrating
thing for me when I see people working
on problems is they start with step 3
they get it wrong and then they start
trying to draw the graph and it doesn't
work because it's inconsistent and the
reason it's some arithmetic error with
the derivative or something like that or
some other misinterpretation and then
there's there's a total mess if you
start with these two steps then you're
going to know when you get to this step
that you're making mistakes people don't
generally make as many mistakes with the
first two steps all right anyway in fact
you can skip this step if you want but
that's at risk of not checking your work
all right so what's the fourth step well
we we take a look at whether f double
prime is positive or negative and so
we're deciding on things like whether
it's concave up or down and we have
these points f double prime of X is
equal to zero which are called
inflection
alright and the last step is just to
combine everything alright so this is
this is the scheme the general scheme
and let's just carry it out in in a
particular case okay
so here's the function that I'm going to
use as an example I'll use f of X is x
over log X and because the logarithm
yeah question yeah
the question is optional so that's a
good question
the is this option okay so the question
is this option was this kind of question
the answer is it's more than just so
imagine instances I mean I asked you to
do this
I'm asking find these things in many
instances are not we ask you to I
strongly recommend that if I don't ask
you to do it that you not try because
it's usually awful to find the second
derivative anytime you can get away
without computing a second derivative
you're better off
so in many many instances on the other
hand if I ask you to do it it's because
I want you to have the work to do it but
but basically if nobody forces you to I
would say never do step four here right
yeah other questions all right so we're
going to force ourselves to do step four
however in this in this instance but
maybe this will be one of the few times
all right so here we go just for
illustrative purposes okay now so here's
the the function that I want to discuss
and the range has to be X positive
because the logarithm is not defined for
negative values so the first thing that
I'm going to do is I'd like to follow
the the screen here because if I don't
follow the scheme I'm going to get a
little mixed up so the first part is to
find the singularities that is the
places where F is infinite and that's
when the logarithm the denominator
vanishes so that's F of one plus if you
like so that's one divided by log of one
plus which is one
over zero with a little bit of
positiveness to it which is infinite and
second we do it the other way and not
surprisingly this comes out to be
negative infinity all right now the next
thing I want to do is the ends so I
called these the ends and there are two
of them one of them is f of zero from
the right
f of zero plus so that is zero plus
divided by log zero plus which is zero
plus divided by well log of 0 plus is
actually minus infinity that's what
happens to the logarithm it goes to
minus infinity so this is zero over
infinity which is definitely zero
there's no problem about what happens to
this the other side so this is the end
this is the first end right the range is
this and I just did the left endpoint
and so now I have to do the right
endpoint I have to let X go to infinity
so if I let X go to infinity I'm just
going to have to think about it a little
bit by plugging in a very large number
I'll plug in 10 to the tenth here just
to see what happens
so if I plug in 10 to the tenth into X
log X I get 10 to the 10th divided by
the natural log of 10 to the 10th which
is 10 to the tenth times 10 times log so
the denominator this number here is
about two point something two point
three or so so this is maybe 230 in the
denominator and this is a number with
ten zeros after it so it's very very
large I claim it's it's big and that
gives us the clue that what's happening
is that this thing is infinite so in
other words our conclusion is that F of
okay so what do we have so far for our
function we're just trying to build the
scaffolding of the function and we're
doing it by taking the most important
points and from a mathematicians point
of view the most important points are
the ones which are sort of infinitely
obvious or the or the ends of the
problem so that's that's where we're
heading here we have a vertical
asymptote which is at x equals 1 right
here so this is x equals 1 and we have a
value which is that it's zero here we
also know that when we come in from the
sorry so we come in from the left that's
f 1 from the left we get negative
infinity so it's diving down it's going
down like this all right
and furthermore on the other side we
know it's it's it's climbing up so it's
going up like this I'll just start it a
little higher than that all right so so
far this is what we know oh and there's
one other thing that we know when we go
to plus infinity it's going back up all
right so so far we have this now already
it should be pretty obvious what's going
to happen to this function so there
shouldn't be many surprises it's going
to come down like this
let's go like this I'm going to turn
around and just go back up all right
that's that's what we expect so we don't
know that yet but we're pretty sure all
right so at this point we can start
looking at the critical points we can do
our step two here we all leave a little
bit more room here and see what's
happening with this function so I have
to differentiate it and it's this is the
quotient rule so remember the function
is up here X divided by log X so I have
a log X
squared in the denominator and I get
here the derivative of X is 1 so I get 1
times log X minus x times the derivative
of log X which is 1 over X so all told
that's log X minus 1 divided by log X
squared right so here's our our
derivative and now if I set this equal
to 0 at least the numerator the
numerator is 0 when X is equal to e the
log of E is 1 okay so here's our
critical point and we have a critical
value which is f of E and that's going
to be e divided by log E which is e
again because log E is 1 so now I can
also plot the critical point which is
down here and there's only one of them
and it's at E that's kind of not to
scale here because my blackboard isn't
quite tall enough it should be over here
and then at slope 1 but I dipped it down
alright so this is not to scale and
indeed that's one of the things that
we're not going to attempt to do with
these pictures is to make them to scale
so the scale is a little squashed
alright so so far I have this critical
point and in fact I'm going to label it
with a C whenever I have a critical
point I'll just make sure that I
remember that that's what it is
and since there's only one the rest of
this picture is now correct that's the
same mechanism that we used for the
hyperbola namely we know there's only
one place where the derivative is zero
so that means there are no more
horizontals so there's no more
backtracking it has to come down to here
get to there and this is the only place
that can turn around goes back up it has
to start here and has to go down to
there it can't go above zero
do not pass go do not get positive it
has to head down here alright
so that's that's great that means that
this picture is almost completely
correct now and the rest is more or less
decoration we're pretty much done with
the way it looks at least schematically
okay however I am going to punish you as
I warned you you know we are going to go
over here and do this step for it and
fix up the concavity all right and we're
also going to do that a little bit of
that double-checking okay so now let's
again just I want to emphasize we're
going to do a double check this is part
three
but in advance I already have based on
this picture I already know what has to
be true that F is decreasing on 0 to 1 F
is also decreasing on 1 to E and F is
increasing on E to infinity
all right so already because we plotted
a bunch of points and we know that there
aren't any places where the derivative
vanishes we already know it goes down
down up that's what it's got to do now
we'll just make sure that we didn't make
any arithmetic mistakes now by actually
computing the derivative or staring at
it anyway and making sure that it's it's
correct ok so first of all we just take
a look the numerator so L prime remember
was log X minus
one divided by log X squared the
quantity squared so the denominator is
positive so let's just take a look at
the three ranges so we have 0 less than
X less than 1 and on that range the
logarithm is negative so this is
negative divided by positive which is
negative that's decreasing that's good
and in fact that also works on the next
range one less than X less than e it's
negative divided by positive and the
only reason why we skipped one again is
that it's undefined there there's
something dramatic happening there and
then at the last range when X is bigger
than e that means the logarithm is
already bigger than 1 so the numerator
is now positive and the denominator is
still positive size increasing so we've
just double-checked something that we
already knew all right so that's that's
pretty much all there is to say about
step 3 so this is checking the
positivity and negativity and now step 4
there is one small point which I want to
make before we go on which is that
sometimes you can't evaluate the
function or its derivative particularly
well so sometimes you can't plot the
points very well and if you can't plot
the points very well then you might have
to do three first to figure out what's
going on a little bit all right you
might have to skip
all right so now we're going to go on to
the second derivative but first I want
to use an algebraic trick to rearrange
the terms and I want to notice one more
little point which I as I say this is
decoration for the graph so I want to
rewrite the formula maybe I'll do it
right over here another way of writing
this is 1 over log X minus 1 over log x
squared all right so that's the another
way of writing the derivative and that
allows me to notice something that I
missed before
when I solved the equation log X minus 1
this is equal to zero here this equation
here I missed a possibility
I missed the possibility that the
denominator could be infinity all right
so actually if the denominators infinity
as you can see from the other from the
other expression there it actually is
true that the derivative is zero so also
when X is equal to zero plus the slope
is going to be zero let me just
emphasize that again if you evaluate
using this other formula over here this
is this is 1 over log 0 plus minus 1
over log 0 plus squared that's 1 over
minus infinity minus 1 over infinity if
you like square any way it's 0 all right
so this is 0 the slope is 0 there that
is a little piece of decoration on our
graph it's telling us here's our going
back to our graph here it's telling us
that this is coming in with slope
horizontal so we starting out this way
all right that's just a little little
start here to there to the graph it's
horizontal slope so there really were
two places where the slope was
horizontal
now with the help of this second formula
I can also differentiate a second time
so it's a little bit easier to do that
if I differentiate one over the log
that's minus log X to the minus 2 times
1 over X plus 2 log X to the minus 3 1
over X alright and that if I put it over
a common denominator is X log X cubed
times let's see here I guess I'll take
the 2 minus log X ok so I'm now
rewritten the formula for the second
derivative as a ratio now to decide the
sign you see there are two places where
the sign flips the numerator crosses
when the logarithm is 2 that's going to
be when X is e squared and the
denominator flips when X is equal to 1
that's when this the log flips from
positive to negative ok so we have a
couple of ranges here so first of all we
have the range from 0 to 1 and then we
have the range from 1 to e squared and
then we have the range from a squared
all the way out to infinity so between 0
and 1 the numerator is well this is a
negative number in this so minus a
negative number is positive so the
numerator is positive and the
denominator is negative because the log
is negative and it's taken to the third
power so it's if this is a negative
number so it's positive divided by
negative which is less than 0 that means
it's concave
down all right so this is a concave down
part and that's good thing because over
here this was concave down so there are
no Wiggles it goes straight down like
this and then the other two pieces our f
double prime is equal to well it's going
to switch here the denominator becomes
positive so it's positive over positive
so this is concave up and that's going
over here but notice that it's not the
bottom where it turns around it's
somewhere else all right so there's
another transition here this is e
squared this is e so what happens at the
end is again the sign flips again
because the numerator now when X is
bigger than e squared becomes negative
and this is negative divided by positive
which is negative and this part is
concave down and so we didn't quite draw
the graph right there's an inflection
point right here which I'll label with
an eye and it makes a turn the other way
at that point all right so there was a
wiggle there's the wiggle still going up
still going to infinity but kind of the
slope of a mountain all right it's going
the other way
right this point happens to be e squared
e squared over 2
okay so that's as detailed as we'll ever
get and indeed the next game is going to
be avoid being is to avoid being this
detailed so let me introduce the next
step subject which is maxima and minima
okay now maxima and minima maximum to
minimum problems can be described
graphically in the following way suppose
you have a function alright here it is
okay now find the maxima
alright aha
and find the minimum okay so this
problem is done okay the point being
that it is easy to find max and the min
with the sketch okay it's very easy the
goal the problem is that the sketch is a
lot of work we just spent you know 20
minutes sketching something we would not
like to spend all that time every single
time we want to find a maximum minimum
so the goal is to do it with so our goal
is to use shortcuts and indeed as I said
earlier we certainly never want to use
the second derivative if we can avoid it
and we don't want to decorate the graph
and do all these elaborate subtle things
which make the graph look nicer and
really or aesthetically appropriate but
are totally unnecessary to see whether
the graph is up or down
alright so let me just so essentially
this whole business is out which is a
good thing all right
unfortunately that those early parts are
the parts that people tend to ignore and
are which are typically are often very
important so let me just first tell you
the main point here so the key idea key
to finding maximum so the key point is
we only need to look at at critical
points well that's actually what it
seems like to in many calculus classes
but that's not true this is not the end
of the sentence and end points and
points of discontinuity
so you must watch out for those if you
look at the example that I just drew
here which is the one that I carried out
you can see that there are actually five
extreme points on this picture so let's
switch I will take a look there are five
places where the max or the min might be
there's this important point this is as
I say the scaffolding of the function
there's this point there's down at minus
infinity there's this there's this and
there's this only one out of five is a
critical point so there's more than you
have to pay attention to on the function
and you always have to keep just schema
the picture of the function in the back
of your head even though this may be the
most interesting point and the one that
you're going to be looking for so we'll
we'll do a few examples of that next
time